[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory for today's video i wanted to
discuss a moment
from the prisoner of azkaban film that
i'm sure
a lot of you never noticed it's a creepy
observation
that will make you want to re-watch the
scene and may even force you to watch
the films
in an entirely new way taking note of
every little detail
in an effort to find more strange and
similar occurrences
what if i told you that in the films as
early as the prisoner of azkaban
lord voldemort the dark lord resided
within the walls of hogwarts
not only that but he was there in plain
sight
and entirely undetected this would have
given him direct intel
into the life of harry and allowed him
to observe the staff
and students of hogwarts without fear of
repercussion
how could that be possible you might ask
well
let's take a look approximately 25
minutes into the prisoner of azkaban
film
students are making their way up the
stairs towards the portrait of the fat
lady
however it's important to note that the
portrait of the fat lady
isn't the only portrait in the frame as
there are also portraits hanging on
either side of the staircase
harry along with his fellow gryffindors
are preoccupied with sharing their
common room password with the fat lady
but if you look to the lower right hand
side of the screen
you will see something that you can
never unsee lord
voldemort or at least a figure that very
closely resembles him
while the fat lady sings terrorizing the
other portraits in the castle
one portrait in particular is enjoying
it smiling and dancing along
and of course it's the same portrait
that appears
to depict voldemort hogwarts portraits
depict
dead witches and wizards that have
before dying
contacted a wizarding painter a witch or
wizard
and is able to immortalize them in
portrait form
according to pottermore the subject of a
magical portrait is sentient
due to enchantments placed on the
portraits by the painter
the portrait will be able to use some of
the subject's favorite phrases
and imitate their general demeanor based
on how the subject appears to the
painter
however they are limited in what they
can say or do if we take a closer look
at this portrait
it resembles voldemort in every way it
has the same
black cloak the same color skin what
appears to be
no nose and even the same head shape
whether this is actually voldemort or
not is entirely up to viewer
interpretation
and sure i guess the portrait could
possibly
just be a vampire which voldemort
closely resembles
but it really does look like him to me
the primary issue with this is of course
that
portraits depict dead people and at this
point in time
voldemort is certainly not dead however
voldemort is famously known to create
what that's right horcruxes just like
with the diary of tom riddle
where voldemort is able to preserve a
memory of himself
that appears to be just like him in
every way there is always the
possibility that voldemort
always had a secret horcrux right inside
of hogwarts
a horcrux that takes the form of a
painting
voldemort began experimenting with
horcruxes at a very young age
and so it would sort of make sense in a
way that he would immortalize himself
in the finest school of witchcraft and
wizardry to grace the wizarding world
the same place that his powerful
pureblood ancestor salazar slitherin
had founded when he would have created
this portrait
is untelling as it depicts his later
physically altered form
and not his original boyish form however
the nature of the portrait depicting his
later form
would likely provide greater anonymity
as many did not actually know what he
looked like
until the second wizarding war this
would of course mean that
after voldemort's defeat he was still
alive
spying on the students of hogwarts for
generations
always plotting and waiting to make his
proper return
what do you guys think was this just the
portrait of a vampire
or does it somehow have a connection to
voldemort
if so what is that connection let me
know in the comment section below
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forget to live